quand est ce que je serai remboursé
puis je faire une cure thermale cette
année je pars en vacances à l'étranger
est ce que ma mutuelle voyage avec moi
vous avez toujours plein de question
pour nous et c'est tant mieux car nous
sommes là pour y répondre
téléphonez nous ou demander à être
rappelé tout est clair et précis sur
notre site
une mutuelle qui vit avec vous votre
quotidien
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien
revenez clic et on en parle
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
check-up votre magazine santé et
bien-être
au programme de ce numéro l'hiver
approche et avec lui le temps de se
faire vacciner contre la grippe ''on
nous vous expliquerons pourquoi
puis nous nous sommes rendus à une
séance de rappels de vaccins organisée
par le ps nous verrons pourquoi il est
important de ne pas rater ces rendez
vous le 13 novembre était la journée
mondiale du cancer du pancréas
à cette occasion nous vous parlerons de
cette maladie méconnue des français
et puis pour terminer avec la proche des
fêtes nous vous parlerons d'un mal qui
les accompagnent souvent les
intoxications alimentaires et pour
commencer nous sommes en plein milieu de
la campagne de vaccination contre la
grippe à tous les ans à voisins le
bretonneux des séances de vaccination
gratuite sur rendez vous sont organisés
cette année ce sont 184 vie si noah qui
ont profité de cette opération
un événement organisé tous les ans par
la ville à l' approche de l'hiver grâce
à la participation bénévole de médecins
on écoute leurs recommandations donc on
le fait surtout chez les gens à risque
les gens âgés depuis 30 ans les gens
risquent de diabétiques asthmatiques
même les enfants fait on le fait aussi
beaucoup aux enfants
et puis gens qui sont réutilisés les
gens qui veulent ne pas manquer le
travail par exemple c'est important que
ça va aussi dépendre est une grippe
c'est
ça peut être bénins chez les gens
effectivement qui ont des défenses
immunitaires qui ce qu'ils soient clic
ce qui sont corrects mais si les gens à
risque si c'était ça peut être ça peut
être mortel se prémunir ses hygiène
demain parfait quand les gens tous il
faut puisque tous effectivement dans sa
manche un dans sa main pareil pour le
mouchage il faut se bouger et puis après
se laver les mains même si maintenant
les manceaux se sont appuyés sur
jetables mais si la main après le
mouchage n'est pas lavé ses porteurs de
virus dont tous les mouches âge tout et
puis effectivement la vache de moi c'est
important
malgré la proche de la saison hivernale
et de la vaccination contre la grippe
qui l'accompagnent les rappels reste
tout aussi important c'est pourquoi
l'institut de promotion de la santé à
trappes organise une fois par mois des
séances de rappels de vaccination
gratuite
ces séances en présence d'un médecin
sont destinés aux populations les moins
suivis médicalement on regarde un
reportage sur des images de jérémy
quesada et méningite
grâce à cette séance de rappel gratuit
ces personnes originaires du bangladesh
vont pouvoir pour la première fois de
leur vie bénéficier de vaccins organisé
une fois par mois par l'institut de
promotion de la santé à trappes
cette opération permet de venir sans
rendez vous mettre à jour son carnet de
vaccination ont fait en priorité les
vaccinations obligatoires
donc sur tout le disque hérite d'un ce
polo et après on peut en fait aussi les
vaccinations qui sont très recommandé
l'hépatite b le ror rougeole oreillons
et rubéole peut informer les populations
les moins suivis médicalement n'ont
souvent jamais eu accès à ces vaccins
auparavant les patients ont d'abord un
entretien avec l'infirmière souvent
difficile à cause de la barrière de la
langue
c'est souvent des étrangers c'est
souvent des 10 et des gens qui sont
démunis ou qui sont réfugiés d'ailleurs
quelques fois le questionnaire très
difficile puisqu'il parle pas très peu
ou très mal le français
à la fin de la consultation un carnet de
vaccination et remis aux patients s'ils
n'en avaient pas auparavant
pour l'instant à l'essai ces séances
permettent également de se faire
vacciner contre la grippe à condition
d'apporter son propre vaccin le 13
novembre a lieu la journée
internationale du cancer du pancréas une
maladie méconnue des français qui mérite
pourtant toute notre attention
on écoute la cancérologue christelle de
la fouchardière qui nous l'expliquent
c'est un cancer développé aux dépens du
pancréas qui est un organe situé dans la
cavité abdominale en arrière de
l'estomac
c'est un organe qui participent à la
digestion est également la régulation de
la glycémie le cancer touché environ 12
mille personnes par an en france est
responsable d'un certain nombre de décès
on estime qu'en 2020 il sera la deuxième
cause de décès par cancer parmi les
facteurs de risque du cancer du pancréas
on peut citer notamment le tabagisme qui
augmente par deux ou cinq le risque de
cancer de pancréas et également l'alcool
par le biais de la pancréatite chronique
et puis on cite également des facteurs
de risque héréditaire il faut savoir que
le cancer du pancréas est un cancer
fulgurant pour lequel l'espérance de vie
à cinq ans est inférieure à 5%
il est donc important de se mobiliser
pour faire avancer la recherche
écoutez pascale hamel gastro entérologue
qui nous explique pourquoi il est
important d'intégrer les patients aux
essais cliniques
je vous rappelle que c'est un cancer
très graves comme vous le savez est que
en regard seulement 2% des fonds dédiés
à la recherche pour le cancer leçon pour
la maladie du pancréas à cet effet il
est vraiment important que et les
patients et les personnels soignants les
médecins se mobilisent pour concevoir et
réaliser de nouveaux essais
thérapeutiques qui permettent
d'améliorer les soins par des stratégies
thérapeutiques optimisé mais aussi par
la découverte de nouvelles molécules
toujours plus efficace
michel est atteint de cette maladie il y
a un an et demi on lui a diagnostiqué un
cancer du pancréas et il nous a raconté
comment il a vécu l'annoncé de la
nouvelle
et ses premiers mois avec la maladie
suite à des examens
aulas va dans mon laboratoire chez un
chef rick j'avais quelque chose de ces
graves un même terrain et c'est vrai que
je vous cache pas que c'est extrêmement
difficile
à l'approché des fêtes de noël avec
toute sa famille oui oui à un choc
émotionnel un terrible mais génie quand
même pacifiquement à un mois avant de
refaire surface
oui je me dis ah bon allez vous voyez
donc j'ai perdu 8 kilos en un mois mais
duo chocun pas dû à la maladie
vous l'avez compris pour un patient la
non d'un cancer du pancréas est un
véritable choc
la cancérologue christelle de la
fouchardière nous explique comment elle
prend en charge ces patients et les
accompagnent après l'annnonce de la
maladie on essaye de le prendre en
charge le plus complètement possible
c'est à dire de façon multidisciplinaire
le plus précocement possible parce qu'on
ait fait le cancer du pancréas est un
choc pour le patient quand on lui
annonce ce diagnostic et il a besoin
qu'on puisse l'aider de différentes
manières autour de son médecin traitant
qui va garder son rôle de chef
d'orchestre on va voir gravité
différents spécialistes dont notamment
l'oncologue digestif mais également un
médecin nutritionniste une diététicienne
parfois un kinésithérapeute un médecin
des soins de support c'est à dire de la
douleur et puis également des
psychologues et cette prise en charge se
fera pour le patient et également pour
son entourage
vous avez maintenant compris pourquoi il
est important de se mobiliser pour cette
deuxième édition de la journée mondiale
du cancer du pancréas
pour plus d'informations sur la maladie
rendez vous sur le site internet
www.fondationdefrance.org
nous allons maintenant nous intéresser à
nos assiettes et à ce qui peut
transformer un bon repas en une mauvaise
expérience en raison d'une intoxication
alimentaire
quelles sont les causes de ce mal qui
vous touchent souvent en période de
fêtes c'est la question qui a été posée
à jean marc sapori médecins dans un
centre anti poison
alors souvent il peut y avoir des
confusions c'est que le produit est
toxique à la base mais par mégarde il va
être avalé ça va être un champignon
qu'on va confondre avec une amanite
phalloïde ça va être des baies de
belladone qu'on va prendre pour des
baies comestibles ou des plantes et puis
vous avez tout ce qui va être une
contamination durant la phase de
ramassage de transport ou de préparation
qui peut être lié un contaminant
extérieur chimiques ou qui peut être
tout simplement parce que les mains
n'étaient pas propres ou les ustensiles
de cuisine n'était pas propre
les intoxications alimentaires peuvent
se manifester de différentes manières
elles peuvent aller de simples douleurs
abdominales a des douleurs beaucoup plus
grave et pour les éviter
quelques gestes de prévention font
parfois toute la différence ses gestes
sont des gestes assez sobre et des
gestes d'hygiène de base
il faut bien sûr se laver les mains bien
soigneusement dès que l'on va préparer
le repas avoir des ustensiles de cuisine
qui soit propre à voir respecter la
chaîne du froid ça c'est un élément
extrêmement important
une grande majorité de ces intoxications
surviennent parce que la chaîne du froid
n'a pas été respecté on va consommer des
quantités modérées des aliments et on va
éviter de donner à certaines personnes
fragiles des aliments qui peuvent être
quand même à risque et je pense en
particulier champignons ne va pas
redonner aux enfants en bas âge comment
se comportaient lorsqu'on est victime
d'une intoxication alimentaire
quels sont les gestes à adopter mais
surtout comment se remettre sur pied
après une intoxication c'est le docteur
jean-marc sapori qui répondent à ces
questions la conduite à tenir et les
fonctions de est ce qu'on a à faire une
personne fragile je pense en particulier
aux enfants de moins de deux ans aux
personnes âgées à des personnes qui ont
des maladies par ailleurs qui sont
dénutri voir déshydraté par exemple en
était là où il faut être extrêmement
attentif certainement consulter
rapidement sinon on va surveiller
l'importance et l'évolution des signes
si les signes persiste plus de 24 48
heures si les gars et sont extrêmement
abondante soit elle
apparaissent de manière sanglante où il
s'il ya d'autres signes qui peuvent
inquiéter
à ce moment là il faut avoir un avis
médical en urgence il ya une détresse
vitale avec le 15 ou auprès d'un médecin
généraliste ou d'un service d'urgence
dans les autres cas donc il va falloir
s'hydrater de manière très abondante
donc avec des eaux minérales avec des
bouillons de légumes
s'il ya des nausées des vomissements on
peut consommer des petites gorgées met
donc de l'eau d'united dans un premier
temps on reprendra progressivement avec
d'abord des aliments comme le riz sans
résidus et sans fibre
puis après avec des légumes et des
fruits qui seront bien cuit et puis
secondaires mans avec des fruits qu'ils
pourront ne pas être cuit à ce moment là
mais on est déjà un peu à distance on
peut compléter aussi avec des
probiotiques et on se met au repos
puisqu'on est dans le bien fatigué bien
déshydraté on se repose durant cette
période de trois jours qui suit
l'intoxication alimentaire
passons maintenant à l'agenda deux dates
à retenir la mutualité française
d'ile-de-france et la commune de la
verrière propose un atelier destiné aux
parents et aux professionnels de la
santé pour découvrir l'environnement du
nouveau né un programme de prévention et
de promotion de la santé qui existe
depuis maintenant deux ans pour en
profiter c'est le 20 novembre à 10
heures à la maison de quartier du bois
de l'étang
et puis un deuxième rendez vous toujours
à la verrière venaient assister à une
soirée de spectacles débats en compagnie
d'un clown philosophe qui vient raconter
ses histoires vécues en cancérologie et
en soins palliatifs pour réveiller le
spectateur à la nécessité de la joie en
milieu hospitalier
on regarde tout de suite un extrait ça
fait 40 ans que j'ai pas entendu ma
maman chanter
sanaa gens de terre ils savent tout de
tout sourire c'est le fun
et pour oublier il a bu cancer du foie
dépressif plus plus plus
pour assister à cette représentation
poétique rempli d'humanité rendez vous
au scarabée le 8 décembre
voilà check up c'est maintenant terminé
quant à moi je vous donne rendez-vous
dans deux semaines pour un prochain
numéro
et d'ici là prenez soin de vous
à